is a city of around 8 million people
we have to work not only on convincing
people that fossil fuels are a thing of
the past but we have to have people feel
safe both using public transport and
riding their bikes or walking across the
city colombia's bustling capital has an
ambitious climate action plan aiming for
15 reduction of greenhouse gas emissions
by 2024 a 50 reduction by 2030 and
carbon neutrality by 2050. i am carolina
i am the secretary of the environment or
the deputy mayor for the environment for
bogota
emissions that come from the
transportation sector account for 48
percent of bogota's greenhouse gas
emissions and are also related to one of
our worst environmental problems air
quality transportation has really been a
main focus of our environmental policy
in general electrification of buses
which are our main source of public
transport has been a focus of the city
our second possibly most important area
is solid waste and water management
particularly because we have a landfill
and we're still burying a lot of our
waste and we really are proposing a
model of a circular economy that is very
hard to get started so we're really
working hard with the government and
with local actors to ensure that the
incentive system in place improved these
projects that are very ambitious and
take four eight ten twelve years to
build we really have to stay the course
in every city across the world you have
a street that is just evocative of the
city carrera septima is one of our
historically most important streets one
of the main ideas that we had was how
important it was to have this symbol of
how we are redistributing space we're
having only two to three ways for
private cars to use that street and
we're making a much larger space for an
electric bus system so that people can
sort of
re-significate and relate to public
spaces to be a street where you can walk
on where you can enjoy nature and where
you can feel connected to the mountains
that's around the city the city's
infrastructure for bicycles has been in
development since the 80s but that
doesn't mean shifting the urban
landscape towards sustainability has
been easy everybody wants
a more sustainable city conceptually
when we ask for those small sacrifices
that we all have to make everybody's
kind of protecting their own rights for
example to private cars i think in
general cities have to convince through
action we have to prove that it can
happen and that it can make people's
lives better